the first teaser for the final season of
Game of Thrones debuted on HBO so far
the only footage we've seen from this
season was in a trailer for HBO's 2019
lineup there we saw Daenerys Targaryen
and Sansa Stark meeting for the very
first time rather than giving us a clip
of new footage we instead gun extended
scene that will not actually end up in
the final season naturally it left us
with a lot more questions than answers
here's a breakdown of what we saw in
this Game of Thrones Season 8 teaser the
teaser is called the crypts of
Winterfell the first thing we see is Jon
Snow walking down a dark hallway in
Winterfell scripts with torch in hand he
walks past a statue of Lyanna stark
that's when we hear this is a callback
to season 6 episode 10 the winds of
winter it's in the Tower of joy which we
see in a flashback of sorts thanks to
bran Stark who is now the three-eyed
Raven in the scene Liyana has just given
birth to John and Ned arrived at the
guarded fortress
Fiona you know
Liana is asking Ned to protect John from
Robert Baratheon Robert at that time was
supposed to marry Liana
but John isn't Robert's child no he's
Rhaegar Targaryen Sun Leone and Ray
Garza fair of course made Robert mad
leading to Robert's rebellion which
ended with Robert on the Iron Throne but
more than anything this scene is
definitive proof that John is a stark by
blood and also has a claim to the throne
because he's Rhaegar Targaryen son which
makes John a Targaryen the Senate of
Aerys Targaryen the Mad King obviously
at this point John doesn't know he has
Targaryen blood because he wouldn't have
you know now the next one might seem
like a minor detail but it's actually
very important in the teaser we see a
feather land on the ground later in the
teaser we'll see that same feather
freeze the feather is actually a call
back all the way to the pilot when then
King Robert Baratheon places it on
Liana's [ __ ] statue we saw it again in
the fourth episode of season 5 sons of
the harpy in which Sansa visiting her on
statue sees it and picks it up the truth
about Jon Snow is hinted at in both
episodes featuring the feather in the
pilot King Robert and Ned discussed
Rhaegar and Lyanna for the first time
when Robert says he dreams of killing
Rhaegar every night Ned replies by
saying the Targaryen czar gone not all
of them Robert replies the episode then
cuts to Daenerys and Viserys Targaryen
but we now know that they weren't the
last surviving Targaryen the feather
second appearance is in season five when
Sansa visits the crypts after returning
to Winterfell while standing at Liana's
crypt she notices the feather and picks
it up she and Littlefinger discuss what
happened between Rhaegar and Lyanna
Sansa repeats a widely accepted
falsehood about Rhaegar and Lyanna
he kidnapped her and raped her that he
captured her against her will and
brought her to the Tower of joy but
Rhaegar and Lyanna were actually in love
and secretly eloped together
I am Huss she is mine from this day
until the end of my days
Robert's rebellion was built on a lie
Littlefinger doesn't correct Sansa but
instead gives her knowing smirk next in
the teaser we cut to Sansa walking down
that same passage way she walks past the
Catelyn statue which seems to almost
whisper to her we then see Arya Stark in
the background we hear the rest of this
quote the full quote is come to my
company
[Music]
it's all because I couldn't love a
motherless child
this comes from season 3 episode 2 dark
wings dark words she's talking - Talisa
Robb Stark's love in the woods on the
way to Lord Edmure Tully's funeral
Catelyn is under the impression that
John is Ned's illegitimate child from an
affair in this quote she regrets not
being a real mother to John and letting
jealousy take over when my husband
brought that baby home from the war I
couldn't that Catelyn died never knowing
the truth about John but she's right
about how John's entrance into her
family has complicated things but it
could also be the thing that sets things
right if John takes the throne at King's
Landing
then the teaser gives us a cameo from
another character that we haven't heard
from in ages it's a statue of Ned Stark
who sees him 1 death in the episode
Baylor shot the world and set the tone
for the entire series John turns to the
statue as we hear you are a star
beyond my blood this was from season 1
episode 2 Kings Road it's an important
line you honest dog you might not have
my name behind my blood this was perhaps
our first hint in the show at John's
true parentage back in season 1 a lot of
us thought this was confirmation that
John was Ned's son but turns out it's a
bit more complicated than that Ned said
this as he sent John off to become part
of the Nights Watch prompting John to
ask of his mother is still alive then
Ned promises that the next time they see
each other they'll talk about his mother
and never see each other again
[Music]
finally John Sansa and Arya unite the
three of them look upon statues of
themselves as if building next among
winter fells dead so we know what the
three siblings will probably unite at
Winterfell and based on the earlier
snippet Daenerys will be there as well
when two fellas you know Chris next they
draw their swords and face off against
the coming ice storm this feels like
fairly obvious foreshadowing to the
show's final epic battle the stage for
this was set in the season 7 finale the
dragon in the wolf in the episode before
this one beyond the wall the whites and
white walkers successfully killed
Daenerys dragon bazarian
the night king then reanimates the
dragon finally giving them a weapon
powerful enough to bust through the wall
and make their way into Westeros
this teaser was just a taste of what
season 8 will be like and while didn't
even show us any actual footage from the
new season it seems to perfectly set the
tone but this was the most important
piece of information from the teaser the
eighth and final season of Game of
Thrones premiers on Sunday April 14th
until then we'll just have to wait for
the first trailer to debut so what did
you think of the first teaser does it
give you any hints about what's to come
let us know in the comments